welcome back everyone to my round four
recap from Beale in this one I was
playing cannot Master Lucas Forester
yolamus who is a pretty young player and
uh so far this tournament I I've played
young players I think three out of four
games he is a junior and in the first
round he beats a player rated in the
2400s so coming into this I was ready
for a tough fight but this game was
actually surprisingly
shorts and I think I'll just leave it at
that and let's hop into it I decided to
play a move on move one that I almost
never play in tournaments or online
do people hear that someone call an
ambulance
or someone already called an ambulance
oh it's getting kind of loud uh I might
have some sound filter or something
okay the ambulance is passing
what was I saying
oh yeah so I play the move that I almost
never play the move Knight to F3 the
reti opening ready some people criticize
me in the comments and tell me it's
reiti but uh it's an opening that I just
never really got into over the years
um but it's a more flexible opening and
it can transpose into a lot of different
things like for example if you play C5 I
could play E4 and go into a sicilian if
he plays D5 I could go into a London uh
if Knight F6 it can go into a zillion
different uh types of variations but he
very quickly played Pawn to D5 and this
surprised me a little bit because
I would have expected him to take a
little bit more time
to decide his first move given that
there's no way he would have expected
Knight F3 from me on move one and I did
check his online games beforehand and I
was more expecting either Knight F6 or
C5
but I'll have to save my preparation for
those moves for another day because he
played D5
and here I I was already like not quite
sure what approach I should take I was
considering playing D4 and transposing
into my bread and butter London opening
but I decided to play Pawn B3 and I
guess I'll go ahead and reveal that uh
if he were to play C5 I was gonna play
B3 in this position and I was basing my
preparation off a game that he played
against Vladimir kramnik entitled
Tuesday where eventually he played D5
Bishop B2 and I have six E3 uh basically
he got this position against kramnik
kramnik was white and just won a really
nice game it's basically a reverse nimzo
Indian Queens Indian but very nice kind
of positional game from the white side
so when I played Pawn B3 I was kind of
hoping to transpose into
some kind of line that resembled what he
played against kramnik but here he still
played very quickly starting with nav
six I played Bishop B2 and then he plays
Bishop to F5 so if you were to play C5 I
would have been in some pre-game prep
but Bishop F5 was not on my computer
before the game but this is a position
I've had before with the black pieces uh
because I I like to play the London is
white and against this specific setup
I've played this position many times as
black as well basically a London down a
Tempo and I still had a general idea
what to do even though it wasn't
specific preparation I started with Pawn
to E3 he played Pawn E6 and I played
Bishop to E2
and I was trying to remember some Hikaru
Nakamura games because Hikaru plays a
setup a ton in online Blitz and bullets
as E3 B3 I think he's made more popular
over the last few years uh just winning
a lot of games very cleanly and the
point of Bishop E2 is a bit subtle but
I'm trying to prepare Knight H4
and I'm preventing the prospect of
Bishop G4 so if black just develops I
could play Knight H4 right away and
essentially get the bishop pair uh this
bishop can run but it can't really hide
after D3 and I think this would be a
nice transformation for white even if
black opens H file uh the two Bishops in
the long term can just offer some nice
chances to play for a win later on
so for that reason going back after
Bishop E2 he very quickly played H6 and
the ball is back in my courts I decided
to play Pawn to C4 which is one way to
contest the center creating the tension
between the pawns and then he pretty
quickly played Pawn to C5
and one thing I want to note is a part
of my pre-game preparation was actually
looking at his previous games in the
tournament and seeing his time
management
and for a lot of players like the time
management isn't really a relevant part
of pre-game preparation but I did notes
beforehand that in his previous games he
played basically every opening and every
game beyond the opening just very very
quickly there's at least one game he
played where he finished the game with
over two hours on his clock and it was
over 60 moves too so I had the sense
coming into this game that he would play
very quickly in the opening even if it
was a line that he was not so familiar
with and I think part of the strategy
kind of showed in in this position and
maybe part of the the deficiency in the
strategy for him showed because C5 is
just I think a clear inaccuracy usually
black should play C6 and keep this more
solid triangle if I can draw arrows
triangle formation with a ponds the
drawback of C5 is it's a bit committal
and it creates the idea for white of
eventually taking I do take right away
now if he takes back with Pawn at some
point I'm gonna play D4 and essentially
Force the trade of d-pawn for C pawn and
that will leave black with an isolated
Queen's Pawn which can be a long-term
positional liability so in this position
I took a bit of a think because I wanted
to play D4 right away but I wasn't sure
about lines with Bishop takes B1 like
for example D4 Bishop B1 Rook B1 Queen
A5 and there's times where I lose
casting rights and maybe lose my a pawn
or walk into some like eventual takes in
Bishop B4 check
so after taking a few minutes and trying
to calculate these lines I realize I can
just keep things very simple and start
with castling just get the king safe not
worry about checks along the diagonal
and there's basically no way for black
to stop D4 on the next move so yeah I uh
I was feeling good here he continues
with Knight C6 I play Pawn D4
and he plays Bishop to D6 I think this
was his first longer think of the game
uh spending about six minutes to play
this move
and after D4 I think the position is
already a little bit uncomfortable for
black because if he takes I take back
with Knight and it gains Tempo on the
bishop uh so this would be very much in
White's favor and meanwhile Bach wants
to Castle but in order to Castle you
have to move the bishop and moving the
bishop also loses time because I can
take on C5 and
um yeah black is just losing time in the
opening so after you play Bishop D6 I
was
thinking I would just take on C5 very
quickly but I took some time here and
realized there's another option where I
just still leave the tension between the
pawns and create additional ideas in the
position and I ultimately played Knight
to C3 which I think is a nice way to
keep possibilities open in the position
also just keep ways for black to go
wrong here Knight C3 of course leaves
upon tension but it creates ideas of
Knight to B5 to harass the bishop on D6
and he told me after the game that he
thought maybe he should play Bishop E7
instead so the bishop doesn't get
harassed but one reason he played Bishop
D6 was to stop potential 95 ideas which
didn't actually cross my mind
but going forward from here uh he does
Castle and I go ahead and play Knight B5
hitting the bishop and now it's a bit
awkward for black because he either has
to allow Knight takes D6 or okay of
course if the bishop moves back this way
I just win the pawn on C5 and if he
moves back to E7 then I would take and
black is losing a lot of time moving the
bishop oh my computer battery is low
again I keep forgetting to plug it in
uh where's my charger
here is my power adapter here's my
charger
this is how
technology works
look look
yeah okay
we're good I think
I managed to not electrocute myself
what was I saying
oh yeah I was saying that black is just
losing a lot of time moving the darks
for his Bishop because we just saw
Bishop D6 Bishop E7 Bishop C5 and then
black is losing even more time after
Knight D4 I'm kicking the bishop on F5
so going back
to this position he did not move his
Bishop from D6 he took on D4 which
allowed me to take the bishop and I was
happy to do so and then I take back on
D4
and this was actually quite reminiscent
of my second round game at least in
terms of the pawn structure it's another
kind of dream scenario for whites with
uh the knights blockading the isolated
Queen's Pawn on D5 now in the second
round game I'll link the recap somewhere
probably below uh if you saw that game
you'll know that it didn't have a happy
ending uh I spoiled what was a very nice
position my opponent was very
resourceful in finding uh counter play
but in this game it's just harder for
Block to orchestrate any active play
especially after his next move taking on
D4 generally when you're playing against
the iso Pawn it's to your benefit to
trade minor pieces
sorry there's a loud motorcycle outside
having some distractions today let me
say that again so generally when you're
playing against isolated Pawn it's to
your benefit to trade minor pieces
sorry there's a loud motorcycle outside
having some distractions today let me
say that again so generally when you're
playing against isolated Pawn it's to
your benefit to trade minor pieces
and yeah now it's just a dream position
I have the Queen Bishop battery on the
long diagonal my other Bishop is ready
to come to F3 on top of that I'm uh I'm
actually tying Down The Rook to
defending the A7 Pawn
and for that reason he pretty quickly
played Pawn to A6
now when he played Pawn A6 I basically
knew what I was gonna play but then I
realized that there's a really nice
tactical idea that I can set up in the
position and I didn't want to spend so
much time here to give him time to think
to maybe realize the Tactical idea so I
played my next move uh relatively
quickly Bishop to F3 and at first this
just looks like a very natural improving
move putting more pressure on D5 but on
the surface it doesn't seem like this
move has a threat
and he responded with Rook C8
essentially ignoring the the threats
that I made with Bishop F3 and in this
position there is a completely crushing
move for whites uh this is white to move
and win material and I do urge viewers
if maybe you didn't see the game already
or you don't see the move in the
position feel free to pause the video
and find the move that my opponent
overlooked
and he actually told me after the game
that a couple seconds after he played
Rook C8 he saw what is coming now I took
some time just to make sure that
everything works out but the move that I
played is Pawn to E4
and the reason why this is so strong uh
there's actually a lot of things
happening in this position I should go
back and just address the fact that
there's two pins in this position even
though it looks like E4 has controlled
many times by the lock pieces uh the
Knight is pinned to the G7 pawn and the
D5 Pawn is pinned to the queen which is
not defended on D6
so for this reason E4 is just completely
working tactically because he can't take
with the Knight or the pawn and if he
takes with the bishop I just take back
and he can't recapture because I'm
either mate or win the queen
so uh yeah so E4 at first it looks like
I'm gonna win the pawn on D5
but it's even worse for black because
I'm more interested in of course either
winning the bishop or getting the fork
of the queen and the Knights and it
turns out there's no way for black to
not lose a minor piece in this position
and I did feel a little bit bad for my
opponents given that um yeah he just
kind of stumbled into a losing position
very quickly out of the opening maybe as
a result of just not taking enough time
and doing the blunder checking but he
did take some time here to just cope
with a reality and we played a few more
moves uh Queen E6 I stacked the bishop
and then Rook to C1 and I was expecting
him to resign a bit sooner uh but we did
play a few more moves now in this
position he played Rook E8 and I was
actually hoping that he would go for a
different line I was actually
anticipating Rook C2 and there's a funny
line here Rook takes C2 Queen takes C2
and I would have happily gone into this
and played Rook to C1 but black has one
trick to play Rook E8 and say oh no my
queen and of course I would not take the
queen because it's checkmates so if we
went into this I would have played H3
and said oh yes my Luft uh just creating
the the pocket of error for the white
king but that didn't happen instead he
played rookie here I still make Luft for
my king and after a few more moves I won
the pawn on V6 and then I trade on F6
and he resigned
so it was a very quick game uh I think I
finished less than an hour after the
round began so I was not expecting to
have a game like this but um can't
complain had some time to relax a little
bit
um actually after the game I didn't
relax immediately I joined the
commentary for about an hour the
official commentary of the tournament
with Grand Master archers like songs and
spent at least 45 minutes chatting with
him and showing this game but also
commenting on the top level Grandmaster
games as well so that was super fun I'll
leave a link if uh if anyone watching
wants to check that out they are doing
commentary daily for the top section for
the super Grand Masters but yeah it was
a pretty quick day at the office I do
appreciate everyone tuning in to these
Recaps as usual all the links will be in
the video description if you want to
analyze this game in more depth if you
want to check out the pairings or
standings or my twitch Channel where
Jonathan trance is doing commentary
daily uh do send some love to him but uh
I'm gonna wrap it up try and find some
food stay tuned for round five which
begins in about 20 hours from now so
look forward to that and I'll see you
guys soon